see you man see you how are you I'm good
man's big baby are you doing brother
good to see you man it's been a pleasure
having Mike how are you everyone would
you guys get comfy
no worries my god Mike how are you man
good man I was watching I'm a big fight
fan I was watching a Friday as one or
two back and just like went heavy into
like Google and just like reading all
about you so when this came through it
was like yes you know just so busy these
days trying to like may enjoy my time
but as soon as I saw this I was like
let's do it for sure excited for you man
I'm excited about the next chapter man
it's good about to get interesting for
you cuz I really follow the sport so
like over the next 18 months it's all
gonna play out so it's gonna be
interesting that uh that undercard
exposure was that exposure you got that
week before were you on the undercard or
Dilip no he was to meet me for door
tease well it was a it was a month
before right yeah in Berkeley right yeah
that was good timing that was like I was
watching like like I've been watching
from afar like the awareness of you
building up and I feel like that last
fight was the one that like people like
okay that guy's in the mix now like
whoever wins do those two guys he'll
like you know I feel like you're right
on the cusp now is that what you guys
feel - yes what's that
oh you mean people actually wanted to
fight I know who the [ __ ] wants to fight
you other you know you know hundred
percent I wasn't a hundred percent so it
was like once you get into the fight
game for real fourteen four years old
why'd it happen bouncer oh oh - as a pro
kickboxer only losing - Mirko Cro Cop
who's like one of the best of all -
close your eyes enough I love fighters
man even fighters have never lost
fighters of member loss
no I mean why just transition just the
up you thought the cultural opportunity
you're getting bored like weird money
like yeah kickboxing kind of been the
forefront of where I got my start in
from yeah and then when I finally had
guys I got I got suspended ain't get to
a five-way the sensei
and that was it [ __ ] I love it so who
are you you're I'm just a friend yeah
yeah more where I'm an entrepreneur
yeah no no PR business a modern PR
business yeah meaning we get [ __ ] yep
and yeah I probably introduced you to
Harvard Marcus that's right that's right
that's right that's right I have a lot
of people in my life that like they'll
see that I know you and everybody wants
to know you everybody wants this this 15
minutes with Gary Vee they want ya they
want to pick your brain so humbling yeah
it has to get so bad cuz I want to meet
you too I was like yes like I love it
honestly it's the best man it's the best
the best because for me when I go into
this I go and click in like a fight mode
I go into like I'm just gonna give him
everything I can give him right like
which is why people want it cuz I'm
really I got enough I don't want nothing
I want to give it and I like it and it's
cool it's fun fun especially like hip
hop or boxing like things that I really
[ __ ] with then it's like triple fun
right how can I help but people say like
oh Anna Kournikova that she was really
[ __ ] good she was a top 40 player in
the world she was just beautiful and
like she focused she was so culturally
relevant that it was hot I couldn't
agree more
I mean I believe in that the most right
okay so we're at a place where we are
arguably like one of the best in the
entire world at this right now but right
now it's like how do we get our name how
to drill get his name from you know a
contender to the guy that is the is the
guy that's making the most noise I got a
I got like you have I got a lot of ideas
first of all boxing content culture on
Instagram is a huge opportunity for you
right like it's like if I opened my
Explorer right now basketball boxing
right like I'm
even sad to myself and why I'm like why
are all the pretty girls gone like am I
like still not a dude like it's all just
boxing but you know how like I'm like
that's by the way that's the biggest
tell who somebody is like if you really
want to who the [ __ ] you are
yeah I know who you are you're
scumbucket like like you know like like
you could really figure yourself out
real quick I so what do they have all
these boxing and meme accounts right
they're stuck because nobody is Anna
Kournikova yet all they got is clips so
one of the things you absolutely should
do is we should map those 16 to 25
accounts and be like yo access interlink
24/7 on those 37 accounts when you're
not even prepping for a fight so you
follow what I'm saying 24/7 even when
you're not prepping for a fight aka
documenting your life this right now on
those box beanie content there's only so
many times you can show me the [ __ ]
ricky hatton got knocked out by Manny
Pacquiao clip right so only so many
times you can show while they're
swinging wide right so right so I think
you should hit up those accounts hit him
hard to be like what would bring you
value and then you got to chop him up
you got to chop yourself up with like
okay I'm gonna give this guy this story
like but but that's gonna get you
serious exposure in the micro community
, next we got a reverse engineer you
what else do you [ __ ] with music what
other sports what what else do you [ __ ]
with we it's just it's honestly just
doing what I look for me people know I
like the Jets people know I like people
they're like like what else so you
understand you got to work exactly what
you're doing now you got it you're
already on the pieces but now it's about
where like not letting not overthinking
it people were thinking where the
attention is without understanding where
it is I would give a [ __ ] about him way
more right now if he did 37 different
interviews with those new accounts and
they clipped it for one minute where he
calls out this guy he compares some
stuff to that guy he talks about Michael
Doakes in this he talks about Mike
Tyson's punch-out and that he talks
about [ __ ] yeah I'm showing you
listen I'm really about the sport my guy
you know like you know you know that's
it yeah you DM riddick bowe and be like
yo come through let's chop it up for an
hour
eat some burgers and [ __ ] makes it
you see where I'm going yeah hack it you
put in the work it's just like bigger
commitment for right now why I'm not
going with it
I love podcasts being on then doing them
but like you the boxing things real
interesting like boxing will never admit
it but UFC did a lot of good for boxing
it really did
the contemporary nature of what UFC and
Dana White did from a marketing
standpoint created an underbelly boxing
didn't Heyman didn't do it like but the
cultures doing it yeah and you know like
you understand yes like it's real fun
like I really like it like I'm and I
really love boxing so it makes me happy
so I think it's just putting work
putting in work you know in the boxing
lane and then just for you know it'd be
great if he could commentate on UFC the
most knowledgeable boxer that's legit
about UFC but here's the point if he
doesn't know about you've seen [ __ ]
with UFC punked it the reason I win is
there's a lot of things I know what to
do but I don't go there because it's not
authentic like I could be much bigger if
I penetrated like California vans
skateboard culture I know exactly how to
do it I know exactly how to have the
meetings with them like skateboarding
that much like I like Nigel semester at
for skateboarding I like when Casey does
it I like Roger you guys like Tony how I
like it but I don't like it I can't
bring up Michael Doakes you know what I
mean I can't tell you like why Julian
Jackson's the best boxer of all time you
know what I mean in skateboarding so you
need to reverse engineer your thing like
what else like what would you say your
biggest like interests are UFC boxing
the kickboxing then I'd know I provided
connections with people and it was
I've been talking to so I've been
working with a company lately trying to
get the producing theme try to get the
consent request arms owner try to you
know introvert arm to hip hop back into
the fight game a little because it's
kind of that over you said before in the
boxing game in America it's kind of like
kind of like taking a fetus that because
it every base though so I'm trying to
might bring some of the rappers back
into the lab and they're coming they
want to come back they're following like
they want it they like it but it's not
like it was to your point you know what
is the New York front especially there
with Mike Tyson's myself II from the New
York Brendan everybody would jump on
that Babic as a New York out we have
such a culture rich a hundred or so so
that's my teacher I'm trying to front of
me just to get that one deep you know
that one big video to go borrow can I
can I give you you're gonna love this
because you can this make so much
[ __ ] sense to you my guy that's like
the person that's like somebody who
thinks they're gonna lay on one big
punch or have one big fight like all
that work you put in the gym it's not
you're not gonna make that one big video
that one big moment you got to put in
the work seven got like you no idea what
it is what we do like right you got it
like it's just not gonna happen it's
like the fighters you peed all the time
they're looking for that one big shot
but you have skill that's why they're
easy for you you're like you got to make
sure you don't get hit by that shot but
other than that it's a rap right that's
how I think about your content game and
what you're trying to do in culture
you're gonna do it wrong you're looking
for that moment it's gonna be this it's
not gonna be this this will be good
we're gonna watch this and you're gonna
get some more fans and good [ __ ] will
get me will try even harder because I
want you to win but the twenty seven
boxing meme accounts the [ __ ] in
you sure I'm going you got you got to
either put in the work or you're not
collaborate I love the idea of
collaborating with the old boxers like
one of my favorite things it boxing that
grew up with was there was that neat how
old are you
you like pot you've always liked boxing
yeah so it's a hair underneath I'm 42
you still probably caught it there's
that era where like the Tyson's and the
Holyfield they were starting to mesh
with the Foreman's and the Ollie's and
the Frazier's they they're like those
nights together mm-hmm
exactly you know like that stuff
nobody's doing that right now like
nobody's reaching out to rittick bow or
Doakes or like you know that you're like
there's some stuff that I think could be
done because finally there's some heavy
with the fact that people can name three
American heavy weights or at least three
non Eastern Europeans Joshua's in UK kid
like the fact that they can name you and
then or even or like if they're even
slight if they're into boxing the fact
that or teeth like the fact that you
could name black eyes not just European
like like this is a moment there's some
there's some underbelly [ __ ] to be done
today don't know don't know the Beastie
Boys are the good man know like people
from ten years ago and its thing cuz
guess what when you and I were fourteen
we didn't give a [ __ ] who people [ __ ]
with and rock-and-roll either we're just
talking old man talk you and I now you
don't know the Beastie Boys are of
course I'm fourteen I know who little
zan is I know Kelly is do you like you
know they don't give a [ __ ] the same way
we didn't give a [ __ ] twenty years ago
yeah little Sam [ __ ] this is Tupac we
want to murder him but like that's just
life that thirteen year old girl in
Oklahoma she wants to get a face tattoo
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about Tupac I
know it hurts but guess what somebody
did some Elvis - right right we didn't
live right like what you gave a [ __ ]
about Motown like that those icons they
gal this for example like there's an
underlying sad era there's an underlying
respect but I promise you right now if
we go to Brooklyn right now they don't
have the proper respect for Smokey
Robinson sure the end that's all you're
talking about we'll everything so
fragmented you can't have that one hit
show now right and so on the train of
modern-day PR right here's what I would
say longtail him like you know you got a
train you got to stay focused but like
whatever times available and clearly if
you guys are talking Anna Kournikova
you're talking my talk because now
you're thinking about at white like look
him and I and everybody nobody's gonna
affect what's gonna happen in the
squared circle but you right so like to
that point it's smart to think about
Anna Kournikova some people hear it and
they're like yo you're gonna get
distracted you need more get the belt
yet mm-hmm because that's gonna play
itself out one way or the other
exactly but like all the other ancillary
stuff is exactly right if you can become
culturally relevant like it's just
different and listen Floyd and McGregor
have shown all the kids the blueprint
there's like culture it's much more Hulk
Hogan and macho man it's Vince McMahon
more than it's like what we think
meaning if you can be the biggest brand
that really matters man like if you know
Pernell Whitaker is all time sure but
like you know he didn't go about it that
way you know but people became like the
the HBO's 24/7 like the the lead-up to
the HBO fights so language employed was
discovered by the world they fought no
Jolla and they did that lead up show on
HBO some people became emotionally
attached Bregman the same way boxes the
wait the same way that the same way that
Vince McMahon would show you mr. perfect
six Saturdays in a row before he ever
came in and buy the team here oiled in
you were so amped the [ __ ] do you think
I'm doing the [ __ ] do you think I'm
doing what are you guys doing here
storytelling so you either do it
yourself like you've been doing I love
it but for the distribution when you're
still at where you're at you got to go
somewhere else the problem is everybody
thinks you need to go to like right like
the biggest thing breakfast okay Gary
Vee breakfast club
I want like it all makes sense but
before you get to that look just do a
bunch of little I'll do little ones
right now I was doing a little podcast
yesterday we did timing up broke down I
was looking at I was like won't part of
my brains like [ __ ] are you doing this
thing that nine people gonna listen to
and the other part was like this is
exactly why you're beating everybody
well everybody spending 80 hours trying
to figure out the plan of how to get on
the six things you're just doing stay
inactive right just say yes
yeah
makes sense right like hit like you know
hit up a bunch of twitch can suit and
play [ __ ] ring King him I'm ranking
didn't even know what you're too young
even rich rain King is an NES boxing
game Mike Tyson's punch-out is all-time
like that what like was the greatest
[ __ ] thing that ever happen to me
nobody loved Mike Tyson more to me
because I discovered him before he went
mainstream and everybody in school
thought it was the coolest cuz he became
[ __ ] Mike Tyson I've been talking
about this dude Michael Tyson because I
used to really watch ESPN and ABC
worldwide you know I'd have to wait for
HBO ring King was the game the real
boxing game of Nintendo on twitch
everybody's playing fortnight and like
League of Legends and all this new [ __ ]
you probably your cousin told you cuz
[ __ ] Drake went on with ninja it
finally became cultural but the real
[ __ ] Jam like the real Jam for
authenticity is uh is uh playing
old-school games like you just [ __ ]
with people on Twitch playing ring King
for Nintendo would be viral as [ __ ] and
that would be your jam people like you
get other fret please hip-hop okay cool
you get Busta Rhymes it's smart right
and I'll do it with you first so I'm
gonna set up a twitch studio outside my
office so you guys will come through and
we'll play and it will go and it's a you
got it's a great game you'll love it
because it's actually like Tyson's
punch-out you know it's one one person
and you're doing this way this was
literally you move like you could really
do [ __ ] I love because I love boxing so
much and like you actually could have
like good strategy it's not like a
[ __ ] game like if you're if you if
you're better at boxing you're better at
ranking than the other person because
you could delete little angles it was
cool
rankings Jim I'm about to tweet nobody
can beat me at ranking see what happens
so you see where I'm going man like to
your point and you have to say to pay
attention I remember that like modern
day PR the same move that you've made
and why you'll win from PR to what
you're doing which actually mean
something I'm like saying go even more
long
tail yeah yeah so what does someone like
that some of the fine print you guys use
me your men
so the to be very honest the thing we're
doing right now in the Vayner sports
side that's really winning is honestly
on some real [ __ ] we're building up
their profiles proper we're setting up
their Shopify stores for real like you
can go Josh Jackson's not even lead yet
you know right eyes again them not even
lead yet but they're [ __ ] calm right
now where you can buy the hoodie and the
Hat and this is so on point like they're
[ __ ] superstar some kind of big in
the game and there's still value
provided for everyone
correct buddy wins scrappy but you've
been like a seventy year you know the
cliche said oh that's 70 year old man
with that 20 year old hot girl that's a
value exchange totally everything you
can't judge people for what they want in
life it's not here to judge right what
maintains this is this you know this
made no he's land in this movie world
and I mean boxing is like said sir while
I west oath at this point is like they
could say again find print a blueprint
now but having Maggie the sudden follow
Bob because it all cuz you're focusing
on fighting is so so strict already
mentally that's physically like it's
like I'm gonna have done that foundation
it's you know that works for you mmm-hmm
that makes sense because when were
making it for small you meet with of
course I got about the lead that they
know the message how long have you guys
known each other five or six years legs
nice a long time yeah how'd you guys get
first connected he was trained in
jiu-jitsu gym that I was training at
ENSO Gracie's oh yeah yeah man that
[ __ ] UFC that I used to watch back in
those days that was some different [ __ ]
yeah he's a special guy hansol Gracie
very very special very very very but he
was training for MMX enough he get
enough respect he does good in our world
that's funny of God
yeah good good he deserves it a hundred
thousand or so amazing human that's what
I know of from a couple of people that
it's cool
yeah man listen it's about it's about
getting the right person or to look I
think you're in a sweet spot here's what
I know
inevitably there's 17 kids running
around right now outside who
really know who you are because they
love boxing there's no other reason
right who understand what he knows and
what I like
you just got to build the right team of
people that are hungry and understand
but I do think it's about Instagram I'm
a guy I really do I think it's a deep
Instagram strategy I think you should I
you have to listen you have to show up
on those boxing highlight clips I'm
telling you it's gonna work you don't
want to be at the mercy of who's gonna
fight you or whatever the [ __ ]
highlights are you only have so many
even Mike Tyson only has so many right
you need to be about you and you don't
need to be calling out people and it's
that it needs to be about the ring King
[ __ ] the other interests your opinion on
it [ __ ] you know just culture right
like you need the social commentate you
know like you should document just on
the phone the first time you play twitch
just like everything just people need to
get to know you
what's your favorite fruit what's your
favorite like what's your favorite candy
so man people need to know so what do we
do like let's go right here like go to
the [ __ ] bodega and [ __ ] pick it up
and if you know you don't to be kept you
honestly you don't have to be
charismatic and beautiful you have to
document Anna Kournikova's beautiful
wallace creepers were just looking at
our pictures on the Internet's why we
liked it like some people charismatic as
[ __ ] the Macho Man is just charismatic
you've just charismatic right some
people overthink it like I don't know
what happens when the camera goes on you
like in that way I know I've seen your
post to interviews but like you know
what I mean here's the good news it
doesn't matter the part that matters is
you love sour pet you know that makes
the connection that's my favorite candy
to hashtag the candy something like once
that you know I I don't know if you know
this is crazy I don't know if you know
this but I have like a I have an
indentation in my head here a little
bald spot it's not it like my hair
covers it but Mike Tyson had that - I
don't you remember old Mike Tyson
pictures he had that little like bald
spot up here like back in 86 87 anyway
style again it's lit no he had the slip
but he has a little indentation okay
that was why I love my caisson huh it's
related to understand want more fans
give him reasons to be your fan
what's the corniest thing you love
that's the [ __ ] question you know
what I mean like do you love Madonna do
you like a soap opera
like do you like you see where I'm going
what's that you need to [ __ ] tweet
you need to sit down watch an episode
and tweet 20 things about it it will
change your world right everybody's
obsessed with the boxer who punches at
different angles that we've ever seen
before that's how I think about it what
some guys from around the way I'd be
like what the [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] I'll
take 10 new fans and my boys razzing me
cuz they're still my boys they're gonna
find out anyway see where I'm going
you're staying in a lane I'm trying to
expand your Lane
but when mobile assembly someone come
across that's the comic-con then we come
to your new Texas and that's alright
except if you don't [ __ ] with comic book
culture then you're just full of [ __ ]
you know like you can add your two cents
on Black Panther because you might say
listen that for me as a black man like
means something like [ __ ] that's crazy
that's true thank you
you are my guy I'm telling you if you
tweet it out like the blue Power Ranger
is the one that will spark a whole thing
and then this is how it works and you're
gonna love this
okay you know maybe you put it out maybe
you know like two minutes
that's the one next thing you know in
two fights you come out in a power
ranger [ __ ] outfit to the that's when
the inside baseball should happen that's
when it's feeding your sub you see where
I'm going and it's authentic you're not
fronting this Franklin coming up black
pants
movies big zoo but that's you riding
something versus it being your own wave
power rangers biggest [ __ ] and always
will be and the recalls the greatest
Michael Doakes makes you smirk got it
the recall there's nobody talking about
Michael Doakes right now you know it's
that got it
and listen you guys can hit me up
anytime ad hoc we can do this again I'm
really rooting for you I'm super excited
about you man I was I've been really I'm
really I was literally just sitting
front of you like wow I was thinking
about like what would happen you know
now that what's happening with me in
culture specifically I'm like okay I'm
just like you know the people you watch
documentaries I'm like oh I'm that guy
you know and so like you were sitting
here and I was like wow if I was just
doing this in an at4
that would have been Mike Tyson you know
it's cool that's why these documentation
is gonna be fun you know yeah yeah we'll
come through yeah yeah look I really
like I'm sure trap exactly if I'm in
time I will be there that will be [ __ ]
I'll be coming down be there
[Music]